foreign
[Music]
the inventor of the bathtub
these dumbasses enslaved us
roll it
oh hello who is this it's your mama if
you're my mother what is your last name
Mel my mother that confirms it
I'm googly Khan Amelia Earhart I am
Sigmund Freud join me for my masturbates
master class what
who are you so call me Jesus Christ Son
of God some call him broken corny
book idea the Kamasutra from Soup To
Nuts if I'm not going slurp stop slurp
I'm eating soup
Judas you pissed on my feet I know you
hear me
you're gonna blow your hands for 30
seconds and you're just not gonna look
at me
sorry I only have big pieces of silver
we are about to embark on the biggest
campaign in the history of the World
Part Two Noah we're supposed to get two
of every animal I got two chihuahuas two
pekingeses two pugs actually I got three
pugs don't tell God
[Music]
what ideas have you got for Shakespeare
what if we do a play but it's got music
and singing
people sing their feelings
[Music]
anyone else with a good idea